hello everyone we're taking a break from
everything just to check up on Lila just
a zero now we don't cover all that many
games that she plays but those that we
do mostly come recommended from you guys
so this is one of the games that has
been recommended by you it's game 61
from the TCC Super Final the top chess
engine competition super final season 15
and it's a storage for the white pieces
against Lee lecture zero d4 is already
on the board sorry about that in a very
nice line of the Trump off ski so for
those of you who enjoy the Trump off ski
this will be just very nice and for
those of you who don't play it all that
often you'll just see it's really a
crazy line which pretty much disregards
developing pieces but it's best for me
just to show you and then see what
happens so in the previous season in
season 14 we've been covering a few
games a little are really played well
and well it's always interesting to
check how a self-learning a neural
network will do against well standard
engines like stock fish and here a
little has been improving by herself and
of course stock fish has been upgraded
as as that goes and it's well now both
of them are in the Super Final and they
are playing I believe it it is a 100
game match so it will be very
interesting to see who comes up on top
so without further ado you've
recommended that so let's check it out
it's really very nice so I do hope you
enjoyed a stock which opens with the d4
we have Knight to f6 Bishop to g5 so the
Trump off ski attack and it's the way
this match goes so the first stock which
plays this line of the Trump off school
with the white pieces and then what
doesn't really matter how the game ends
then legal gets the white pieces and
they have to play the same line so that
way they check out how how Leela deals
with certain openings and how storage
goes with certain openings with Knight
to e4 now attacking the bishop the
bishop to f4 and now c5 just a nice
flank attack in the center with f3
pushing the knight back Queen to a5 with
check
we have c3 blocking and now Knight back
to f6
we have d5 grabbing more space in the
center Queen b6 now pressuring the
bishop to go back as the b2 ponies under
attack and you can't defend it with
Queen c2 or queen c1
because the Queen has to keep an eye on
the d5 pawn so here we have blush up the
c1 a very exciting line as Bishop goes
to afford them Bishop retreats Queen
went to a five then the Queen retreated
to b6 and that's not even even the
beginning we have d6 by Lila now comes
c4 and now II 6 and here this position
has been reached before but there is
only one game in the database for
tonight the a3 was played and here we
have C 4 which is a new move in the
position and it is of this moment that
Stoker's plays c4 that we have a
completely new game never before played
so we have g6 Lula prepares to
fianchetto the bishop we have Knight to
e2 this Knight is now coming to c3 as
this pawn is already on f3 so this night
is coming to the c3 and this night will
come to d2 after the light square bishop
moves to f1 and then depending on what
Leah place the e3 or either g3 so Bishop
to g7 has planned Knight eat the c3 and
here we have castles by Leela with
Bishop to e2 and now comes nicely eight
the White King is in the center so of
course Lila wants to bust open the
center with f5 and with h4 by starfish
and now you can see that really both
both dogfish and Leah are pretty much
playing with the pawns not really doing
anything with the pieces we have h6
so after h5 comes you're ready to
counter it with the g5 but here we have
g4 by stockfish
so again just completely disregarding
any pieces development just lunging you
know forward with the pawns and now
comes Queen back to d8
so very interesting firstly I played
Queen b6 sort Queen a5 then retreated
Queen to b6 and now Queen to d8 and this
is something we've seen alpha 0 do alpha
who will play 7 moves with the Queen in
the opening and then you know just
retreat with the Queen to the starting
squares and it's just everything against
the the principles that you are being
thought when you start learning just you
know don't bring your queen out too
early pull more if you said you know
help your pieces so they can help you
and here as you can see not really a lot
of pieces not play going on especially
from Leila's perspective but if you look
at stalkerish pieces also you know
mostly pong play but okay with Bishop to
e3 finally we have some development with
f5 and now comes f4 stockfish again just
you know lounging forward to going
putting everything into the attack we
have Queen to e7 and now comes 85 and
here Lila blocks with the g5 and now
what do you do here first Queen to d2 by
stockfish putting pressure on this well
launching in front of the king and now
okay if you've seen this position let's
say Knight c3 Queen d2 with this nice
battery of bishop on e3 you have the
bishop on e2 look an h1 all the points
advance you might think yeah this
probably something you know why to
develop the knight and the bishop then
the Queen and then you know he just
started pushing the pawn so but that's
not the case first the point went
forward and only then do we have the
development of the pieces and here you
have a five and now this is a complete
madness on the board I mean look at this
bad boy here just just a massive pawn
structure on the Kings side and what do
you what do you do here I mean it's just
crazy calculating all the captures but
point being if you play something like
let's say G captures on f5 yes you do
get a very nice passed pawn and i-5 but
then again black also gets a very nice
pass pawn maybe not with the G but with
a pawn here on f4 you have to go back
with the bishop and even if you give up
the bishop for two points let's say
something like this you will not I mean
it's it's an interesting idea but
against such such a strong opponent like
Leo of course stockfish isn't interested
in in doing something like this you
would do something maybe if you play it
against your friend in a in a blitz game
but not in a in a serious you know Tsz
super final so here we have F captures
on g5 with f4 now and now we must
consider a few things first of all your
bishop is under attack you could move
the bishop back but also everyone is one
of you but why not G captures on h6 and
it's a wonderful line really just just a
nice human line that well most of us
would go for probably which is very
exciting after you capture on e3 the
queen is under attack so first you have
to react to this
Queen captures on e3 and now Bishop to
f6 is just a grabbing grabbing hold of
the g5 square and now of course you want
the bust open the G file you allow black
to capture and then you pin the bishop
Ruby g1 and now it seems like white is
winning how do you prevent rook captures
is just over I mean you you're gonna
develop your night castle and you just
bring the other look into the game and
white is winning it would be the case if
black didn't have Luke to f4 and now you
don't have a good good follow up with
your attack if you go something like
Queen g3 to capture now now you get
Bishop to g4 completely unpinning from
black and now the point is you cannot
capture if you capture Bishop captures
on g4 then Bishop to h4 traps your queen
so black wins here even even such a nice
check like Bishop to e6 check which is a
double check it doesn't help you black
will just move the king and there is no
good follow up you're still you know
there's no good way to take care of this
Sergio's gonna lose the Queen but it is
a very nice thing you know that we have
to consider just G captures on h6 but it
doesn't work of course stockfish doesn't
go for it with bushel back to f2 and now
just H caps or Sun g5 completely closing
this and now I don't know h6 seems like
a very nice human move you don't want to
allow black to close this with with the
bishop but stockfish has a very nice
idea first we have Queen to d3 and now
Knight to d7 Leela starts to developing
the other pieces we have worked the g1
Bishop to f6 now putting more defense
and here not allowing white to bust open
anything
Knight to d2 stock which starts
developing as well and now Queen to f7
we have queenside castle by starfish and
now Bishop back to d8
here a Leela makes room for the nights
to come to f6 but also this Bishop is
coming to a5 to control this very
important diagonal which you'll see why
it's important later Knight to f3 by
stockfish and now King to h7 we have
looked the g2 preparing to double up on
the G file which you might think but why
double up on the G file I mean the G
file is you know close solid well or is
it with a 6 Leela prepares rook to be
followed by b5 at the bust open on the
queenside s stockfish Castle queenside
and now just look D to g8 and again if
you try something like well there are a
lot of ways of wife can bust open on the
Queen side on the King side you can go
Bush up to h4 let's say if black played
a slow move b6 now try brush up h4 but
black black would never really capture
here I mean but you would put pressure
on the point here black would probably
just have to defend it you you will not
be able to capture because g5 and then
all of a sudden it's a very dangerous
position for black but just one of the
options that you have for at least
trying to bust open the king's side here
we've looked a g8 first and now comes
Queen back to c2 we have King to h8 by
Leela King to be won by stockfish and
now rook to b8 preparing b5 as planned
and now King to a one-stop fish besides
that it's much safer for King to be on a
one with Knight eat f6 here bringing the
night into the game and now Knight the
d1 with Bishop to a5 as planned grabbing
hold of this very important diagonal and
now comes Knight to h4 this was thought
fish the idea and now if you play pawn
captures then you get Bishop captures
and then when this pawn starts marching
forward it will be very dangerous for
Lula to defend this position so after
night to h4 Lilla just said okay just
nice to f8 I'm just gonna defend the g6
square so if your knight ever comes
there I'm just gonna grab it so here we
have Bishop to f3 stop it just blocks
this pawn you don't want a lot F 3 any
tactics might be available but also we
should check what happens after Knight
to g6 check I mean it's a very nice
check you're at least busting open the H
file but does it bring you anything
after Queen captures on g6
sure you can go rook h2 check then the
king will just to go away rook jito h1
you will completely dominate the H file
but black will just ignore you play b5
continue the attack on the Queen side
and you don't really have a good move
here this knight on f6 controls a you
know a lot of a lot of important squares
here and you don't really have a good
follow up on your on your sacrifice so
your stock fish just keeps everything
intact with Bishop f3 now comes b5 Leela
starts
the attack on the queenside Knights to
c3 and now with Queen th trying to bring
the Queen into the attack as well
Knights the b1 and now comes Luke to b7
with Knight to f5 by stockfish and this
is now basically a monster night so you
do have to eliminate it you're not gonna
just leave it there there is an
exception to this rule
sometimes a monster night will just be
given away for example if you've been on
this channel following it ever since
we've been covering the Bobby Fischer
saga then you know the famous game
between Bobby Fischer and taken on
Petrosyan where Fischer gave up the
monster night for for patrols and the
bishop who wasn't really doing anything
and all the grandmasters who were like
wow and that was really a nice moment if
you haven't I mean to check it out it's
a very nice game but it is one of the
exceptions where you will voluntarily
give up a monster night but okay Bishop
captures on f5 we have G captures on f5
and now with night 8 to h7 just you know
keeping everything in check on the Kings
side and our Lila hopes to transfer the
game on the Queen side with h6 finally
this pawn is pushed forward and now
Bishop to b4 here we have Queen to e2
and now comes B captures on c4 and here
just bishop you don't want to capture
here if you capture here then Queen to
b5 will be very strong and just bringing
the Queen into the game of course you
don't want to trade here it would just
improve black's pawn structure so here
at stockfish has something else in mind
first Bishop to e1 and now Queen to d8
just preparing to bring the Queen into
the game we are via Queen to a5 Knight
the c3 now and now you can see that even
though the B file is well semi open you
don't really have any good options for
attack let's save Queen b6 and let's say
Queen c2 you don't really gain anything
Bishop captures Bishop captures and good
luck busting this open I mean this b2
point is protected like well I like a
very important point
so after Knight to c3 we have looked to
be 8 by alia and now King back to be one
with Bishop to e3 threatening to capture
here and now just Knight to a4 stop
which nicely defends everything we have
C 3 by Leela
giving up upon here bushel captures on
c3 and the now Queen to d7 attacking the
knight on a for Queen 31 defending with
Bishop to b4 offering a trade here and
I'll just came to a 1 we have Queen - b7
now with some very nice pressure along
the B file but the v2 pawn is so nicely
protected that you don't really have
have any ways of busting this Queen side
we have Queen to c2 by stockfish now
comes a five Queen e2 and now Queen to
d7 again pressuring the night here just
queen d1 repeating and now Lila doesn't
repeat but rather c4 so little by little
Lila is making progress with a3 pushing
the Bushra back but now comes Queen to
b5 and it is a very nice idea of course
if you capture the bishop then a cap
person before will just be too strong I
mean the king is still on a1 after you
move the bishop then rook to e8 will be
winning as you don't really have a good
way of defending the knight here and
blacks attack will be very strong so
after a queen b5 we have Queen back the
c2 stuff is just wait and see what
happens here and now Queen back the e8
we have Bishop to e2 and now Queen to d7
so from something that you know seemed
like a very aggressive start to the game
we basically enter a very slow
maneuvering game and now what do you do
here if you capture on c4 then Bishop
captures on c3 is the idea after Knight
captures on c3 then g4 and then Levi
just gets a very powerful attack even on
the Kings side
so after this Queen 37 we have Bishop f3
stop it just blocks here and I'm a queen
back to b5 with Bishop back to d1 and
now Bishop captures on c3 Knight
captures on c3 attacks the Queen on b5
we have Queen to c5 Queen to d2 and now
finally Queen to d4 Lilla now offers a
trade of Queens which would improve her
bone structure immensely here in the
center
quinta a1 not allowing this straight and
now Queen back to b6 just assuming this
a very very important file Queen back to
d2 and now comes route to b7 preparing
the other rook to come to b8 with a 4
now this is a very strong setup for
stop Fischer not not very easy to
destroy it we have Queen back to c5 and
I'll just the Queen e1 and here we have
looked Abby for if the knight moves now
the a four point will be will be
vulnerable maybe even giving up an
exchange is a possibility Queen back to
d2 by starfish and now Queen back to b6
we have Queen to c1 and now Queen to d4
once again Queen to c2 and now rook the
b3 even and here again you have to be
careful if you play something like Queen
f2 to offer a queen trade then rook
captures and c3 will be very strong and
now you can no longer afraid Queens do
to rook c1 check first you hide the rook
and then you recapture the Queen and now
of course if you come to pieces black is
just up a piece and of course completely
winning so after Luke to b3 with Bishop
to e2 and now comes Luke captures on c3
this was Leila's plan all along Queen
captures on c3 Queen captures on c3 be
captures on c3 and now of course what's
the idea behind the idea exchange
sacrifice Knight captures on e4 just
eliminating the base of the pawn chain
now making the d5 and ef5 point weak
bonds and then alia plans to make this
massive pawn Center just start marching
forward with Bishop to f3 if King Tubby
- if you try and defend the c3 pawn
Oliva isn't really interested in the c3
point Leela we just go Knight to f6 and
then start pushing the pawns would be
very dangerous for white so we have
Bishop to f3 and now Lila just goes back
with the night and Knight to f6 and now
the idea is the same g4 of course and
then start pushing the pawns
Bushra back to to e2 and now II for now
preparing f3 this way with Bishop
captures on c4 but now g4 and now you
can see the three connected past points
are more than enough compensation for
the exchange sacrifice we have rook to
be to stock which tries to find activity
on the Queen side but now Knight to g5
we have looked the b6 going after the d6
pawn but Lilla just defense at night to
f7 we have pushed back to f1 and now
comes f3 we have c4 by white and now
comes Knight to DS
attacking the rook we have looked a b7
and now the other night takes this nice
place defending it and now this Knight
also blocks the rooks attempt at
attacking the the d6 pawn so white for
the moment is unable to create a
passport of its own we have f6 by white
okay white it does have a passport but
it's very unlikely that it's actually
that these two are actually going it
somewhere with III now e 2 is the idea
and you really don't have a good way of
preventing this we have looked at v3 but
now just e 2 now you do have to give up
the piece we have Bishop captures F
captures and now rook to e3 and going
after the pawn here but now of course
you all see the move 92 f3 attacking the
rook also if you block the pawn then
just Knight captures it and if you don't
do it then the pawn will come to e1 a
square which is protected by the night
so here focused right f7 but Allah just
blocks look to a fate we have rook
captures on g4 and now of course just II
1 bring the Queen into the game rook
captures Knight captures and here stock
which played rock to g6 but it was in
this position as engines usually do that
they both agree that white was black was
simply winning by too much and it was
basically in this position that
stockfish resigned in the game something
we you know before we weren't really use
to hearing something like this
stalkerish resigned the game but ever
since the appearance of alpha 0 this has
been you know something of a common
common thing so a very nice game with
the black pieces by Leo just zero in the
in the trump off skew line if you
enjoyed this game as so many of you have
recommended it we could also show this
exact same line where Leela plays it
with the white pieces if you're
interested to see how that would turn
out so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Tim
Seltzer and the Michael Carr for can
refer to my channel thank you a lot I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos er thank
all for watching and I will see you soon
our continuing coverage of the feeder
Grand Prix continuing the coverage of
the couple Blanca saga checking up on
Leela and of course as this game Kim
came by checking up on your suggestions
I will also be checking up on your
suggestions so this is the game
and yeah I think y'all I will see you
soon have an excellent rest of your day